Anthony feel like no one understands me
come on you're amazing
thinking amazing get me started on that
cute little butt of yours what what
you're so annoying
why can't you chill out are you kidding
what's your problem for Alexander could
you get worse
I can't believe Elliot texted
photoshopped pictures of me to the whole
school
nice boobs Alexander for his family life
couldn't be better
I got a call today I have an interview
for a game design firm you could be
looking at the new vice president of
lone Hill press once I get my license
tomorrow kind of have everything I've
ever wanted
hashtag blessed you know but one day can
change everything shouldn't you guys be
up hey guys all ready for you here you
go first we thought it was a little
weird that you even applied for this job
because we're pretty young and you're
older space is all green it's not
poisonous I don't think it's poisonous
I'll be your driving examiner my
girlfriend probably won't start prom we
never answer the phone when I'm driving
proms don't happen every day hey so yeah
I don't think he passed stay is so
cursed you're not passing the blame on
this heart fault I think that you just
gotta have the bad days so you can love
the good days even more trust me I would
no we are not going to let this day get
the better of us are we ready Coopers
yeah let's go record rau
whose pretty good
is that a pirate's book sold oh I still
have me arms come Alexander and the
terrible horrible no good very bad day
you have no idea the kind of day we are
having